how's it going everybody it's Warren and
the Black Widow theories are starting to
pile up is Black Widow somehow still
alive is taskmaster somehow hot guide
for whatever reason and what the heck
are those red vials that NAT is holding
in the trailer there have been many
theories about what these could be I've
done some myself and I'll link the video
up above but today we have a new theory
that you probably haven't heard yet and
it's most likely the most accurate one
based off of the evidence that we have
and the leaked photos that we've seen
from the set of Black Widow and not to
mention yesterday we saw the reveal of a
black widow Funko pop that happens to
have a red vial in her hand
so clearly this mysterious red vial is
of some importance if they're making a
Funko pop figure with it in her hand so
we'll dive deep into this theory of what
I actually think this red vial is I'm
still doing my xbox one and ps4 giveaway
all you have to do to enter is subscribe
with notifications turned on leave a
like and comment on the video winner is
chosen at five hundred and fifty
thousand subscribers well so much for
the theory that this red vial isn't
really going to be that important in
Black Widow now we're not going to rule
out any of the other theories especially
the one of Natasha coming back to life
because we all really really want that
but what does most likely is as some
sort of makeshift Super Soldier serum
that Thunderbolt Ross is looking for to
turn himself into Red Hulk now this
theory makes perfect sense for several
reasons it's been reported by several
sources that the thunder bullets are
going to be developed it's also been
reported that Black Widow is most likely
going to start the introduction of the
Thunderbolts and the MCU we know that
Thunderbolt Ross is going to be in the
Black Widow movie we saw a weird de-aged
version of him in the first teaser
trailer that we got and we know that in
the comics he is Red Hulk but let's take
it all the way back to 2008 Incredible
Hulk movie and The Incredible Hulk we
are introduced to Bruce Banner who of
course is a scientist a really really
good one he is then assigned by military
general Thaddeus Ross aka Thunderbolt
Ross to conduct an experiment to perfect
the original Super Soldier Serum given
to Captain America during World War 2
his assignment was also to experiment to
find a way to make soldiers more
resistant to gamma radiation of course
we all know how this ends Bruce was
exposed to gamma radiation and he became
the Hulk he then left and went and
searched for a cure but Thunderbolt Ross
followed him he went after Bruce and did
thing he could to track him down and
capture him so we can make more soldiers
like him now fast-forward again to the
first teaser trailer that we got for
Black Widow we see a very very deh
Thunderbolt Ross
so this most likely takes place back in
time which makes sense because it's kind
of a black widow origin story it doesn't
take place in her past in the Red Room
but we are going to explore that so this
is most likely why we see a very Dee
aged Thunderbolt Ross because it's back
in time but why is he interacting with
Black Widow in the past well as I
mentioned before these vials are most
likely some sort of Super Soldier Serum
they're most likely giving these to the
black widows in the Red Room Thunderbolt
Ross clearly finds out about it and is
curious but there may be more to this
than what you think we've recently
gotten some leaked photos of the set of
Black Widow where we see Thunderbolt
Ross and his appearance in these photos
is very sickly he looks like he's in
pretty bad shape and could be dying and
what could be happening here is that
Thunderbolt Ross over the years since he
hasn't been able to capture the Hulk has
been trying experiments on himself to
try and become the Hulk but judging by
how he looks none of these experiments
have been successful and now in the kind
of current time after the events of
Captain America Civil War Thunderbolt
Ross is tracking down everybody who did
not agree to sign the sokovia course and
now Thunderbolt Ross once again finds
himself tracking down Black Widow but
only this time he wants the Super
Soldier Serum that she is trying to
prevent from getting in the hands of the
new black widows because when we saw him
in Civil War he looked perfectly fine
and now we see him in these leaked
photos for Black Widow that takes place
right after the events of civil war
looking like he's dying it seems very
clear that he's been conducting
experiments to try and turn himself into
the Hulk it also makes sense that he
would do this right after Civil War
because he failed to capture Captain
America Bucky Barnes Falcon and Black
Widow he could have had a Thanos moment
where feyo's grabs the gauntlet and says
fine I'll do it myself the same thing
could happen with Thunderbolt Ross could
have said fine I'll do it myself
took a experimental Super Soldier Serum
and instead of turning into the Hulk got
sick so now he seeks these red vials
that have the potential to cure him and
turn him into the Red Hulk let me know
what you think about this theory does it
make sense and would you like to see
this happen leave your thoughts and
theories down below also don't forget to
give the video a like and subscribe when
notifications turned on so you can stay
up to date on everything
to the MCU giveaway rules in the
description down below also don't forget
to follow me on Instagram and Twitter
and as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof